[Music]
g Babinet, hello, hello. I'm
interviewing you today for a website called
ser viw. Well,
welcome. I'd like to get your
opinion on Big Data. What
can you tell us about it? It's
a vast subject, but I think it's
primarily a technology, not
a religion. As such, it
offers
fantastic opportunities, but also significant threats
and privacy issues.
I'll give you an example that I,
Micher, think sums up the point quite well:
with Big Data,
I can fairly easily
predict
people's health status once
I've provided a large
amount of data—historical
health data, for example, DNA or things
like that. The question is
how do we organize this? Do we
organize it individually? Do we organize it
collectively? Do we organize it
systematically?  We do it in
opt-in mode. And what is
opt-in mode? Opt-in mode is based on
voluntary consent. That is to say,
I say I agree to my
health data being processed, and from
there we could say, "Okay, we
warn people, we give them
advice on how they should take care of themselves,
eat,
and so on." So this is
obviously a very different relationship
between institutions and individuals
because it means we agree to
entrust extremely
sensitive data to institutions so they
can tell us, "Be careful, if
you don't do this, in 6 months, in 1 year,
in 2 years you're going to have a
serious coronary heart disease, a chronic illness, of
any kind." So, similarly, we could very
easily say, "In a
given population, it's not worth
vaccinating everyone against the flu
every winter." We can identify the people
who are most vulnerable and
invite them to get vaccinated. And
conversely, we can also tell
other people, "For you, it's..."  There's no need to get
vaccinated because you have a
low susceptibility to
the virus that's coming, so that's
typically the challenge of Big Data. But we can clearly
see that the initial premise is
trust. If there's no trust
in the healthcare system, there are
possibilities for misconduct, on the one hand, and
beyond that, in the healthcare system or
in institutions—well, here I'm talking about
healthcare, but it's true
for everything. For
example, if I take
public transportation or transportation in general,
we can optimize public
transportation thanks to Big Data.
We can optimize not
only public transportation but
also my personal travel.
For example, I could
have a kind of system that
looks in my calendar and identifies when
I go to work,
and then optimizes the
bus routes according to
collective interests.  So,
in this neighborhood, there are
30 people who go to work at T
time, so we modify
the bus schedules in real time, so to speak,
because we see that it's more
relevant, and in this case, it would make the
schedules disappear—yes, yes, if you
were to do the devil's work!—and so, well,
all of this rests on
the principle of trust in the
systems and the principle of fair
reciprocity. But it's obvious that
we can have very
significant slippages, meaning that there's no more
reciprocity and that it's used to
abuse us. So, the example of
healthcare is obviously insurers,
supplemental insurance, and
we think, uh, they're going to refuse to insure
people or they're going to insure them at very high
prices, and so on and so forth.
And that means there's
no reciprocity because there's
an abuse of data that's being
used beyond what we want, and there's no
longer a sense of solidarity. That's the
Common sense regarding the
distribution of the healthcare system, or rather,
the use of the healthcare system... and
so I believe that the principles
guiding the effective implementation of Big Data are
significant
democratic transparency and a debate
on the desired model.
Because I think that since these
systems weren't designed with this in mind, it's
necessary to ask ourselves
how we want to use them.
You mentioned a debate; have
you followed how the
military programming law was passed? Do
you find that there's currently a
debate around these issues,
or that these questions are being raised? Yeah, yeah, I
found it quite interesting.
So I protested against
Article 13 versus Article 20 of the
military programming law, and in fact,
I did so because I
finally understood, rather
late,
that the institutions don't understand,
or at least don't want to
understand, the risks generated by the
institutional models they create. Let me
explain.  Until now,
wiretapping and similar activities
were considered relatively limited, confined
to a purely technical
aspect. Therefore,
a kind of entity could be created to handle
this, and this approach has
continued. My
problem with these
wiretapping systems is that they are linked to
the executive branch and transmit
the results of
investigations to the judiciary. However, this undermines
the very foundation of democratic principles, namely the
separation of powers,
and consequently, the spirit of the law, particularly
Montescu's principles, is severely
violated.
I don't see how the current model, which
prevents the
Rainbow Warrior affair (where
the executive branch completely manipulated the
investigation) from
recurring, prevents the
normal functioning of democracy
from being preserved. This is because, as a reminder,
the wiretaps are carried out by a
military institution, whether requested or
not.  Moreover, the judge and
the judicial police, which is
responsible for conducting investigations, are
obviously attached to the Ministry of
the Interior and therefore are not
independent either. So there is a
real risk of, in
quotation marks, a perversion of the system. I think that
now that our lives are massively
digital—that is to say, if I wear
connected devices, my real life
is very easily monitorable—
I think we need to reconsider the
organization of
our institutions, including
the independence of the judicial police.
Because, well, I consider that
digital investigative tools are
easier to pervert and rig
because they are virtual, and therefore
files can be introduced into
people's computers, than in
real life. Because in
real life, you have witnesses, you have
third parties, you have
material evidence that may or may
not remain, and it's quite different. I
think
that the legislator, whether through
ignorance or ill will, has
really made a prejudicial error.
to the functioning of justice and, more
generally, of democracy, by
implementing this Article 13, 200...
and I believe it's still time to
revisit this, how do we, at the
citizen level,
rethink our institutions or
regain control of these
institutions? But this is a real issue, it's
even the issue, I think, that we don't realize we're entering a new era,
and I
believe we're moving from the era of the Second
Industrial Revolution to the era of the
Third Industrial Revolution, which is the
data revolution, and that this raises
fundamental ethical problems that require
a citizen debate. And this debate isn't happening
because our
institutions consider it the
normal course of things, the normal evolution
of things. Moreover, the
regulation imposed on us, put
in place by our institutions, is out of step
because
it continues to
regulate pro formaly, as if we were
still in an era in which we...
Furthermore, I believe that, uh, it's
essential that the political world
be educated about these issues, and beyond that,
I think there's a
civic awakening that's indispensable, and
uh, I believe we can have a
calm debate on these issues. I believe it's
not a simple matter; that is to say,
technologies allow us to do
interesting things, but also to do
negative things, and we
must avoid an opposition
between the pros and cons, but rather distinguish between the two
and create
an institutional environment that
allows us to successfully navigate this transition
in this new era. When you
were on the National Digital Council, did
you feel you were being
listened to? Uh,
curiously, no, I didn't
feel listened to. Uh,
rather curiously, I felt I had
a relative
independence. There were things on which
it didn't go particularly well.
I think, in particular, we wanted to
have a fairly free voice.
What went wrong?  which went
badly on several occasions. We
expressed our opinions very freely, without, so to speak,
going through the
official channels, and we were
criticized for that, which I can understand. In fact,
as I explained in my
book, we felt it was necessary to be, so to speak,
a kind of "
positive guerrilla warfare," that is, to be engaged
in dialogue but at the same time
to very radically express what
seemed to us to be a new voice—
radically, or frankly, frankly, frankly—that is to say, to say no compromise
and to
say, "This system doesn't work at
all." And, if I remember correctly, I
think the first opinion we had was
on a Telecom Package directive
and on issues of public freedom. I
'm not sure, but I think I'm roughly right.
And that was two days after the
creation of the CNN, or in the
first week after its creation,
and I know that it kind of set the
tone. It was quite funny. I'm going to open
a parenthesis because you're talking about...
Telecom, what do you think of the
somewhat incestuous relationship
between Orange and the DGSE? I've heard about
this, objectively speaking—I don't
want to say anything stupid, I haven't
investigated it extensively—if it's
true, it's obviously extremely
problematic. And
I don't know the case well,
so I wouldn't want to say anything stupid. So,
let's close that parenthesis. What does
the National Digital Council lack to have a real impact? The
current Council is fairly
new, so I don't know if I
could give an opinion.
I think we need to be somewhat
radical. We're
dealing with people who, because they come from
another background, don't fully
understand the issues at
stake and have the impression that it's
secondary. So, I think we need to
issue opinions with a certain
radical edge. We
need to ensure
that these opinions resonate with civil society.
That is to say, I dream of
very broad consultation on
data issues, for example. I think the
challenges of data are extremely
ambitious in terms of
potential, and that this requires not
an immediate answer, but an
ongoing discussion on a whole
range of societal topics. For
example, do we create
electronic identities, and if so, to what
extent do we guarantee that this won't be
a source of abuse? What
type of Big Data system can we
consider for different themes and
different areas?
Should digital education
be systematic, and what
type of digital education? And so on and so forth. All these are
important issues, and I don't
want to entrust them
exclusively to people I
consider to be the most
affected by the digital divide. Because, in my
regular conversations with
politicians and
different segments of society, that's where
I see the biggest
digital divide: the people
who get their emails printed out are
n't necessarily blue-collar
workers.  In the provinces, it's
a bit like the judges
who ruled on the Bluetooth case. Oh yeah,
incredible, with Google. Okay, a
little word on that. Well,
for me, it doesn't surprise me. It's
just the normal course of things in
institutions. So, judges
who haven't been properly educated on these
concepts. Why? Because there's the
age group. In general, the people who
are at the head of this country are
older than the average French person.
Besides, young people don't vote
because they don't feel represented.
And then beyond that, there's
institutional isolation. That is to say, when you
belong to a state institution, you
're a bit out of touch, and as a result, you don't see
real life. You see it less than
elsewhere, and so, indeed, we
witness consequences. And I find
this Bluetooth case rather interesting. That is to say, it
really shows, in an extremely
concrete way, what's happening. And
when I say it, people say to me, "But
you..."  They're exaggerating, that's not how it
works, and so on. Well, if it works like that
everywhere in the state, they don't
understand these people at all.
So you declared in an
interview that the law was an enemy of the
nation,
yes, and I think I wasn't necessarily
well understood by everyone
when I said that. My point was
to say that's exactly what
I just said, which is that I don't see
why the CNIL would risk the debate regarding
data by saying, "Here's how we're going to
regulate it." For
me, the problem with the CNIL is that
they've kept saying, "Yeah, all this
is very dangerous," and I think that in the
end, the message I perceived was that the
best way to prevent it from happening is for there to be none.
And I think that, uh,
whoever doesn't have any, or who is better off with more diverse data, yes,
but that's not what
the CNIL says. In any case, there are
several categories.  There was the CNIL, I think,
before this statement, and since then there has been an
evolution in the debate, in the CNIL's
position on this. But again,
the problem with
the CNIL is confining
a debate that concerns us
all to an administrative institution. And I don't think we can
let the CNIL, or the High
Authority for Health for that matter,
decide how our data should
be processed.
Personally, I would prefer
my data to be used more widely,
but with greater
transparency regarding the
issues at stake, how it is
used, and a greater ability to
decide whether or not to use it. For example, it's quite an
objective. I'll stop you right there; it's quite an
objective. Currently, we're
practically in an era of widespread loss of
trust. Without resorting to
conspiracy theories,
protest, or reactionary views,
journalists are no longer listened to,
politicians have lost the
trust of their voters, and the
protest vote is manifesting itself through the
vote for the National Front.  Nationally, without even
saying that some people vote for the
National Front without even subscribing to their ideas,
simply to cast a
protest vote, we're touching on a very, very
sensitive debate. In your
opinion, what organization or what shift in public
awareness could
restore
trust in the management of our
data? Big Data is something
that can be very beneficial for
the evolution of a society, but it can
also be very, very harmful. What do we do? Do we hold
a debate? Do we
create a forum? Do
you want to be the spearhead to
unite this new era of
trust around Big Data? Are
you ready to reach out to
hackers, to people who are a
little less representative but
much closer to the population? This is
the heart of the matter.
To answer the
first part of the question, I
believe that one of the reasons this
country lacks trust in its
institutions is the very nature of these
institutions, which are...  Neo-monarchical systems
are extremely verticalized. We are the
country in the world with the most elected officials; there
are 600,000 elected officials in France, 630,000 in France.
It's unique in the world. Per
capita, that's one elected official for every 100
inhabitants. And in fact, we do this. My
conviction is that it's to deprive
civil society of direct expression, of
direct democracy. It's the confinement of
debate within specialists, and we are
a society fascinated by
elitism, by the elite, by elites. And
I observe that in many countries,
the institutional framework is evolving
to include civil society in the
debate, and we are very far from doing that in
France. I think it's even a bit of a
terror of institutions. That is to say,
I believe it's out of fear of the "Jaris,"
uh, of the provinces, that we created
institutions that have this form. And
it seems to me that at a time when
institutions are losing ground
to this new
technological reality, we must either force them
to change form or  Creating debate
alongside institutions, effectively
imposing... well, I think by
showing them they don't understand. That's why
I often have rather
harsh words for
political power, because I believe they're driving
the country into a wall, and
beyond that, they're fostering the emergence of
radical thought, particularly the
National Front, that sort of thing. Because for
30 or 40 years they've been
imposing an alternation of debate between the
right and the left, which isn't the
solution. Basically, the debate is whether we
create a
supply-side society or a demand-side society. And I
think that in the digital age, that's no longer the issue.
For
example, the issues of
free labor, of having
open platforms, are absolutely not at the
heart of the political debate, and it's becoming
so significant. I remind you that
the American Bureau of Statistics said that
now, in American growth, there are
figures that can be measured
monetaryly, but there's also a
portion of unpaid labor.  We access
Wikipedia, we access wealth, but
we don't pay for it, and so this is
the concept. It might seem like
collaborative intelligence, yeah,
collaborative intelligence, exactly, it's
these concepts, these concepts. I
think it should be part of the
political debate, but it's
absolutely not. But not only that,
direct democracy is also a matter
of political debate, and I think
they will continue to see a
decline in their trust as long as
they don't take into account the dimension
of the digital society, which has
foundations that have nothing to do with
So,
to answer the question, I think
yes, the problem is that this
debate isn't happening. This debate is necessary. Yes, I'm involved
in bringing it about, and I'm trying
to find
platforms
with
different institutions and
associations to reflect on this. I was just
this morning and yesterday
sending emails about it. I don't
know exactly how it can be done,
and yes, obviously, all
goodwill is welcome. Speaking of
goodwill, I'd like your opinion on
hackers. What do you think? Well,
I don't know the hacker world very well. I
obviously meet some, but
there's no official label
for
hackers. There are several
things in what
the notion of a hacker evokes for me. For me, there's the
notion of alternative thinking, which is
interesting because it's about breaking with
common thinking and saying, well, we can
do things differently. That's
obviously something
I respect a lot. There's
the principle of...  Counterpower, and uh,
obviously in the current period where,
uh, ultimately we have things that are
whispered, that aren't expressed, having
this counterpower is good, and I'm obviously very much in
favor of it. I think
that people should also express
ideas, so not just be involved
in concepts of code and things
that aren't necessarily understood by the
general public, but they should participate in the
public debate. Then there's the
third concept, which is the somewhat
dark side. Obviously, I can't support
people who have certain behaviors. It's
a minority, a minority
that is obviously a minority. I
think so too in general. Uh, a few quick
questions:
you received the title of Digital
Champion. Do you find it
a little ridiculous? Why not?
Why not Digital Superhero? Digital
Superstar? I'd love that. Digital Superhero would suit me
very well. I'd be happy to put on
a cap if Brussels changes the
title. Okay. Two last questions:
Gill Babinet,
if possible, give advice to the younger generations who
listen to us online. What
recommendations would you give them?
If you had to leave a...  A message in a bottle
on the internet, the immortality of this
advice: what would you leave to
these younger generations? Well, there are
several types of advice, there's
advice regarding
professional life, that sort of thing.
So, well, it's silly to say it,
but I think
that mastering a bit of coding is
good, but it deserves to be
said, even if I'm not necessarily in front of
the people most likely to pay
attention to what we know, since they're already involved in it.
I think
alternative thinking is important. That is to say, we're
in a world that favors groupthink
more than ever, and as soon as we
start to step outside the box, we're no
longer within the box. So, I think—and I have no
respect for what I say quite
often—is that in the 60s we had
a flourishing of philosophers and
alternative thinkers, and it was a time when
we couldn't have utopian visions. And
today we're in a
conceptual and technological revolution
that is being led  Through the digital world,
and the fact that we don't see much alternative thinking,
so I think it's
important to express it. And the third
thing I would say to young people is, don't wait to be
given
power, take it. You have to
understand
that everywhere,
the people who hold power won't give it to
you; they'll keep it,
and they'll keep it illegitimately.
I see that everywhere, all the time.
And what's very strange, by the way, is that,
for example, the other day
I was in a newspaper, and they were saying, "
Here you are, part of the
younger generation." I'm 47 years old. I
consider that to be a good example. It clearly shows
how much of a gap there is. Basically,
the people who have been in power for 60 years,
the rising generation is over 40,
and the rest are perpetual minors.
So we can't let things
continue like this. J Babinet, thank you, thank you very much.
[Music]
The idea of ​​the
Trilateral Commission came from David Rockefeller
35 years ago. He
gathered a few dozen  Europeans,
Americans, Japanese, telling them, "
Listen, we have problems in common,
for
example, relations with China, for
example, relations with what was then the
USSR. Let's try to have
common positions that are in the
general interest." We're talking about
data capture, data collection, as the law says.
That is to say, we're going to search from service
providers, from
technical intermediaries. We're going to search for
all kinds of data. It could be
emails, emails, emails, it could be
banking data, it could be passwords. That's what it's all about.
Tomorrow it's permanent, and I was
surprised to see that people aren't aware of
this. We could very well switch to
a much less organized regime with
values. Recently, there was even a FO (Force Ouvrière - a French security service) that did everything in place, used
legitimately by the government in
power, and could automate a
genocide or automate
mass arrests, and that's what scares me as long as we're
in a
democratic state.  I CIS I want to do well I
want to trust our states
[Music]